إنها السياسة التركية فيما يتعلق
بالقضايا العربية
التي أه نوعًا
ما قفزت ما كانت علاقة جيدة مع اليونان
لتكون
علاقة رائعة مع المسيحيين
من جانب الإمارات نعم وأعتقد هنا أن
دعمنا هو أنني أعتقد أننا نتفق جميعًا على أننا
في الواقع ، أريد أن أرى تركيا
أكثر من دولة قومية أسترالية مرتبطة
بحدودها مع
حدود الآخرين وأعتقد أن
تركيا تعاني من أزمة مع العديد من البلدان الأخرى
حول كيفية رؤيتها لمجال
سيادتها وهذا ما أراه هو د.  قرقاش ما
يحدث بعد ذلك في شرق البحر المتوسط
ًا مرة أخرى أنا لست خبيرًا في شر
البحر المتوسط ول
عتقد في تقديري أن الأ
راك أكثر قليلاً مما يمكنهم مضغه و
عتقد مؤخرً
أنك تعرف نوع أه يسحبو
ك  يعرفون أن
سفينتهم فيما يتعلق بالاستكشاف وما إلى ذلك
كانت في الأساس خطوة عقلانية
وأعتقد أنهم أيضًا
مصدر قلق أيضًا لهذا
النهج الواقعي الجديد أيضًا
في قبرص تظهر تركيا أنه إذا ضغطت
بشدة
هناك  سيكون دائمًا رد فعل
وأعتقد أننا جميعًا
نتوق إلى يوم
تعود فيه تركيا إلى ما تعرفه أنت تعرف أساس
السلام في تركيا والسلام في
العالم والذي كان حقًا
تصورًا للسياسة التركية لفترة
طويلة نريد ذلك  لديك
علاقة بناءة مع
تركيا للاستثمار في السياحة ،
فأنت تعرف المعاملات الاقتصادية وما إلى
ذلك ،
ولكن مرة أخرى ، فإن سياساتها تزيد من
تعقيد
علاقات تركيا مع العديد من البلدان
، فهي في الحقيقة
تتعلق بنهج جديد من الواضح
أن النهج القديم للكرسي الفارغ
القديم  نهج
عدم وجود اتصالات لا جسور
وتقييمنا لم
ينجح وأنت تعلم أننا ننظر حقًا إلى
مبادرات ومبادرات السلام المصرية في
أواخر السبعينيات والثمانينيات
كحلقة ناجحة في
نوع من السرد العربي الإسرائيلي وننظر أيضًا إلى
اتفاقية الأردن
بشكل عام كما هو ناجح أيضًا ، فما
الذي تستخلصه من ذلك
هو أن الكرسي الفارغ يقترب من نهج عدم
الاتصال
أه أنت تعرف  أسلوب الخطاب العالي
لا يساعد
أي شخص حقًا
[موسيقى]